hey Doug Walker here I just saw the lego
movie - the second part give you a
little a little background wife of the
first film a first lego movie I thought
was fantastic I think just taking an
obvious advertisement and turning into
something so good people are upset it
doesn't get nominated for an Oscar
that's really an accomplishment Lord and
Miller I think are on freaking fire
everybody how you think they're really
really just knocking it out of the park
and yeah now we have this follow up the
second one which is not directed by them
up it is written by them so you're still
getting you know it's not direct sequel
and this one is also really good I don't
think it's as good as the first one but
my brother and I were talking on the way
out we both agree sort of the themes and
ideas in this one are better the comedy
and the delivery the first one has down
a lot a lot tighter and a lot better the
setup for this one is that you can kind
of guess it it just based off at the end
of the first one cuz I'll say myself
what are they gonna do in the second
film because it's okay I guess I won't
you know you have to spoil if you're
gonna talk about this one
you have to know if the first film is
about to go into the second one so and
so if there's gonna be some first film
spoilers here sorry I you got to know
that so it's revealed at the end the
first one that this is all in the kids
head or mostly and the kids had that
part I didn't like but it's mostly the
kids had that the imagination part it's
him it's actually about him interacting
with his father and they say at the end
you know oh we gotta let your sister
play with you now and that's pretty much
what this is about and that's a great
idea you can can't do a lot of various
things with it and they do and so it's
pretty much kind of the sisters Legos
and toys coming in and they're not
always getting along and sort of she has
her own world and he has his and his is
kind of changing now because of her and
then hers is kind of changing because of
his and the the
they pretty much interact off each other
and the sister toys pretty much come and
kidnap some of the boys toys so now he
has to go the Chris Pratt character has
to go and save them and the sisters
planet and sister's world the sISTAR is
actually what it's called it's very
tempting and it's ruled by this queen
that that's this great anime a character
that that can become anything it can
look like anything and she can transform
into you know whatever she like and it's
just some great great animation this
film is wonderfully animated I mean just
the speed and the energy and the angles
are really great and Chris Pratt Chris
Pratt's character I forget his name I'm
sorry comes across as character named
Rex and he's kind of the version of it's
of himself he's always wanted to be he's
like this very very tough and gruff you
know superhero he has like Raptors that
do computers and workout and stuff like
that and he tries to learn how to be
more manly from him so if that's the
basic setup and I won't go into spoilers
or anything like that pretty much the
the jokes in this for the most part are
really good and they're very much like
the first one that the humor and the
first one is great but it's weird
because you'd have like maybe three or
four just great jokes like men are they
thinking out of the box or man do they
know what we're thinking and then you
know like we're gonna predict the joke
and then they'll go like three or four
steps further and then you'll get a joke
as either just like that first step you
know where it's just a very basic setup
deliver and there's nothing that funny
about it or even some that just don't
even they're just not even remotely
funny like there's one where one of the
characters lands on Wonder Woman's
invisible jet so you just see her flying
any lands and he grabs her throws around
and steals the jet and she goes wait my
lassos in there what why is that funny
like there's a couple jokes like that
where you just can't scratch your head
and say man that kind of that kind of
died which is a shame because like I
said you have three or four jokes in a
they're just real fantastic and then
you'll just have something that's just
like a like a real head-scratcher like
what why was that meant to be really
humorous uh but that still majority of
jokes work the sad thing is when the
joke doesn't work they kind of linger on
it and hold on it for a while and that's
the worst thing you can do for a joke
that doesn't work so you do have those
kind of awkward moments and it's a
little longer - the first one really
felt like it flew by it hit the exact
notes of Nia to hit at din overstay its
welcome I can't say this one overstays
its welcome like it ends on a good note
it's more that there's some parts in the
middle that you feel could have been
snipped or could have been shortened for
example that this one's a musical and
it's great actually then this really
made me realize how much I miss musical
I miss songs and animated movies I feel
like animated films now are trying to be
more grown-up they're trying to sort of
hit every fan base and so they try to
keep songs out you know at least
traditional singing like a musical song
you know a kind of film it's not
something where they just play a pop
song in it yeah it's like that
that doesn't count I'm talking about
actually like I'm gonna sing what I'm
feeling kind of musical and I realize
how much I miss them because so many of
these musical numbers are just so grand
and so cool it's so funny and so
creative and so colorful I'm just with
animation you can just do so much more
than with live-action and so quicker and
so naturally and just so freely it but
there's maybe one or two too many and
you know I bet everyone's gonna have the
exact same song where they think about
it because the movie itself says really
we're doing another song at this song
it's the the Queen has two songs in this
and the first one's fantastic and the
second one's not even that bad that's
too much like the first one and the
visuals are very much like the first one
and it's it's not a bad song it's still
kind of funny but yeah it's the whole
film kind of works like that where
you're kind of like
this is good but you did this really
there's another one so uh but it's never
painful it's never something where
you're kind of rolling your eyes like oh
man this is awful it's just it's
something that doesn't necessarily work
all the time but with that said kind the
ideas that they're working with
especially with the idea of these two
worlds colliding and especially there's
this song the Queen sings about not
being evil and when it's kind of
revealed what it pays off to it's
actually really funny um and I think the
other thing too there's a again without
going into spoilers there's there's
obviously gonna be a surprise about who
Rex is because who is this guy this guy
just comes out of nowhere and suddenly
he's saving the day whatever so they're
obviously gonna be a surprise with that
and as when they first reveal it I'm
kind of like okay I kind of saw that but
not in this way the way they're doing it
seems kind of weird almost sloppy but
then as you during like the final fight
in this between Chris Pratt and this Rex
character you know he kinda even
acknowledges what this is and it's kind
of like okay alright but I thought they
were gonna go more kind of like the Toy
Story 2 round again I won't say what
part of Toy Story 2 but but if you see
it you'll know what I'm talking about I
thought they're gonna do more of that
but but this gets I guess more
imaginative but it's I feel like it
should have been a little bit more
simple who Rex was but still in terms of
again tying back to kind of the ideas
and the themes of what they're doing uh
it's good and it works um the the songs
are very catchy there is literally one
called I was it not gonna be no and now
I'm forgetting the lyrics oh my god the
whole song is about not forgetting it
and I was humming it all the way home
and now I'm forgetting you probably run
the radio so I'm about you can't get the
song out of your head it's pretty much
what it's called
um and I didn't until now so that's it
me is what
viewing live does to you like your brain
panic so you can't think of that song
but I get the shower tomorrow man it's
gonna come right back so uh yeah man I'm
trying to think there's it's just a good
movie it does not work as well as the
first one terms of the comedy but the
animation is better I think the ideas
are better and kind of like the first
film even though I like what they do at
the end where they show what this all is
it did get a little heavy-handed at the
end of the first one like you know again
you could made the reveal a little a
hint shorter and not have to spell it
out as much this one does the same thing
where I felt like man I would have loved
this idea even more if they show less of
the human world and he kind of had to
put together what was going on you know
between these two worlds been to a tweet
brother and sister which they were very
early on this is like a fight between
brother and sister but as you're
watching and you're kind of interpreting
it at the end they show you what was
really going on in all those moments
it's just like you didn't need to do
that like we could have figured it out
um but again that's kind of nitpicking
oh and I will say this even though I
like this movie this is gonna sound
weird the best part of the movie is the
end credits and it's not even like a
visual thing to visually they're done
fine the song they play over the end
credits is very funny so stay for them
there's nothing at like the end of the
credits like there's no reveal there but
the song while the credits are playing
it is very very funny so stay for that
it's like I said I I just looked over I
said I think that's the best part of the
movie and that was a good movie so yeah
I can't think of too much else there's
just something about Lord and Miller
they they they think out of the box and
like I mean everything it did
what was that solo movie gonna be like
god that's all I'm thinking now it's
like this was you know they had a native
preview to previews for Toy Story 4
before this film started which is really
odd that they had two of them and after
seeing this I'm like you know
I'm optimistic I'll wait I'll see but
it's like after watching this it's like
man it's just I feel like these are the
people that these two that are really
doing new things and they're doing it in
the least likely places you know they
have this this movie now supposed to be
a commercial it's literally called the
lego movie and people are Assent than to
get nominate for an Oscar and then they
did the spider-verse which was obviously
supposed to be another reboot of you
know this cinematic universe like it was
like what Sony tried to do in spider-man
what they tried to do with Ghostbusters
and didn't work and they I mean this was
the most obvious of it with spider-verse
and they just turned it to something
fantastic that dick in nmine of for an
Oscar so I these two are on fire right
now and so far these are the two that
just so excited cuz I'm seeing things
that you know people would not put this
much effort into they wouldn't put this
much energy they wouldn't put this much
creativity not that they would put
creativity but they wouldn't put this
much like these are really thinking
out-of-the-box ideas and visuals and and
they're funny and they're charming and
that you want to watch them over and
over and over so yeah anything their
name is attached to now I'm just like I
got a see i got a watch so yeah it's it
is really really good and it does kind
of push the idea a little more which I
like it isn't just a retread if there's
part you might watch it and be like
Anitha this is what we've seen this kind
of idea before but but they do push it
that they do kind of add a little bit
more to it
they establish this world and then they
they build on the world which I really
like so yeah it's a good movie I I'd
like to watch it again honestly I don't
have ya know I still would because the
big-screen visuals are really really
cool like I said especially during the
musical scenes and I would watch it
again
I do wish like it could have been
trimmed down a little bit and like I
said just some of the unfunny or jokes
but I mean the ones that work are still
really really funny and the the visuals
are great it's super creative it's a
good story good ideas it's a solid movie
so go check it out let me know what you
think that's about it I will see you
next time take care
you